before we keep going you wanna hear some
fan submissions of roasts my house Oh a
little roast my hose yeah I got a couple
of Peters I'll dive dish I've just a few
outs of people I'll take some you take
some people you mean me no I mean people
that are undeserving like our listeners
and I want to apologize for that first
one I thought was so funny
Brennan looks like Shia LaBeouf try to
turn into the Hulk but got stuck halfway
[Laughter]
after my contra named Michael honcho not
a real mess you submit that day that's a
real one this next one's from jebbie
dubs this is JB dubs field looks like
the kind of guy to take his parents to
small claim courts over unpaid Shore
money probably about 500 $20 did so much
work and she never paid us man I never
paid us dude and we're supposed to get
paid and at the end of the week we done
things that had lost all the money every
week and I was doing laundry and
cleaning the house and it was just
[ __ ] insane bro and opening a beer
Jesus Christ anyway one more fire that
real it's not funny if it came from
deels mom this last ones for both of you
I thought it was great from chance
coffee y'all look like the Timon and
Pumbaa that didn't make the Lion King
[Laughter]
we look like gran and stumpy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] study that's the best thing you've
ever said
man there's a good man strong where do
you pick those up from there
Oh YouTube also going through the
comments you do Instagram too or no mr.
Graham too but the YouTube lose one
directiy yeah those are funny God you
guys are like Timon and Pumba bro
it's pretty nice that might be the
funniest one yeah but you could lose
weight due to some of it is the times to
what yeah what you have a body of a 14
year old transgender girl find some
dumbbells do a push-up every now and
then bro quit drinking soy lattes
push-up look and talking about working
out put on a push-up bra [ __ ] chubby
muffin good doing [ __ ] yoga and
talking to people about plug in politics
and grab a [ __ ] incline bench all
right we got some debate club skill
detour bro my girl stops let me bust in
or off
so your girl's a chaser bro your people
come this far and you stop at the
[ __ ] start
Wow just say get your blood pressure
checked bro ain't nobody in here in
great shape that's in the best shape
yeah
[Music]